why say yes to this role even though
there are many Ariana's here what
intrigued you x and y say yes to it and
i think any actress wants to do the down
and gritty like it's a hard roll and
it's a fun rule you get to do things
that you wouldn't normally do and also
it's with this movie i feel like it
speaks a lot of dark truth like it talks
about because he loses his brother and
it's shocking like he's there one day
and he's actually just gone the nexus
very honest from a drug overdose and his
little brother never did drugs but he
just got caught up in it and my
character sadly is one of the ones that
got him to do the drugs because he
overdosed on coke and and i think ariana
is very real and a lot of people and I
think seeing it sometimes on screen or
seeing the reality of it it does help
people or kind of like helps people
maybe relate to it in their life and for
me I up with like that type of stuff
around me drugs or whatever and I never
I've never done any so it's interesting
for me to try to dip into what I've seen
and they try to relate to it and I lost
my brother to drugs and so when I read
the script and he loses his brother to
drugs and it's exactly like that it's
you don't expect it
and and my brother lost it to a girl
pretty much was a very late seductive
woman she was doing it all the time she
got him to try it and he did the same
amount overdosed died and that's what my
character and the other girl in it
pretty much do we seduce him he thinks
it's awesome and he passes and a lot of
people think that they can try it once
and be fine or just see what it's like
and that's not true I mean it's no
matter what dangerous so I wanted to
play this part for the fun the layers
and just someone has to so I hope I
represent her well enough that
and the devil's supposed to be beautiful
and seductive and in LA you find a lot
of that type of evil where it seems
wonderful and it seems beautiful and
perfect and you're just getting dragged
down deeper and deeper and deeper and it
was an interesting part for me to play
do you think it was almost meant to be
in some ways yeah I think I think
there's way too many people trying to
work in this business that if you get
something it's probably meant to be it's
such a not a gamble because you work
your butt off to get it but yeah I think
I think anything that happens is meant
to me
you